nun bin ich mit meinem thema dran und
ich freue mich sehr das ist das thema
heute machen kann denn unser
verkehrsminister der auf lediglich eine
infrastruktur zuständig ist ja heute
abbaus andreas scheid ich habe andrea
schorsch einmal getroffen das war 2018
damals waren dafür dass fans bei tätig
und habe mit dem überlässt
flächendeckende handynetz in deutschland
geredet ein thema also was nicht schon
mehrere jahre sehr interessiert weil es
mich wirklich jedes mal nervlich sitze
im zug erwarte einen businessplan 70
dafür stunde habe schon angst dass der
jetzt kommt weil ich genau weiß ich
hänge ja gleich irgendwo und habe wieder
kein netz es ist mir jedes mal
unangenehm und wirklich nicht gehen in
zug und habe angst dass mich jemand
beruflich anruf dann passiert es endlich
dass wir in deutschland flächendeckendes
handynetz haben es ist ja nicht nur so
als hätten wir nur im zug kein handynetz
sondern ich war zum beispiel am
wochenende auf dem land das beispiel
habe ich geschaut aber ist auch schon
erzählt da war ich im sauerland und
hatte wieder kein handynetz zwei tage
lang ich frage mich wann können wir in
deutschland endlich mit flächendeckendem
handynetz rechnen eher scheuer ich kann
mich gut an das interview darüber weil
danach fand mehrere mobile vom gipfel
statt und jetzt sage ich mal ganz
aktuell kommt ein sogenannter diesen
report der europäischen kommission mit
zwei themen nämlich abdeckung gigabit
fähiger anschlüsse da haben wir zugelegt
in den letzten jahren um 15 millionen
14,8 millionen gigabit wenige anschlüsse
das heißt also die leute können schnell
im internet unterwegs sein und zweitens
jetzt haben wir 99 7 prozent abdeckung
der haushalte wo und das ist das
entscheidende wir haben seit unserem
gespräch damals mehrere mobilfunk gipfel
gemacht und zum ersten mal ist es
gelungen dass die anbieter einen
versorgungs plan erfüllen müssen und
wenn sie den nicht erfüllen dann zahlen
sie strafe wir sind in den letzten
jahren besser geworden ich habe ja auch
eine mobilfunk infrastruktur
gesellschaft unter schwere kritik
gegründet um 5.000 weiße flecken zu
schließen und das haben wir jetzt alles
am start ja und ich bin genauso genervt
wenn nicht flächendeckend mobilfunk ist
und man
handygespräche zum abbruch bringt wir
haben auch beispielsweise telekom und
deutsche bahn einen vertrag
unterzeichnet das eben genau die
zugstrecken ausgeleuchtet werden wir
viel dafür getan ja und sie haben recht
es ist nicht zeitgemäß für eine
wirtschaftsnationen dass wir nicht zu
100 prozent abgedeckt sind aber wir
haben in den letzten jahren noch einiges
erreicht das geheimnis liegt in dem
begriff haushalte ja was ich eben gesagt
haben also fast 100 prozent der
haushalte aber eben nicht der fläche
sind abgedeckt das ist ja also in
verzögerungs reichen regionen kann man
gut telefonieren sobald man rauskommt
noch meck pomm oder sonst wohin fährt
niedersachsen richtung küste ist es
aus weil da halt relativ wenig leute
leben das ist nach wie vor so und ich
habe nicht verstanden ehrlich hat das
werfe ich ihm jetzt persönlich gar nicht
vor da saßen viele mit am tisch dass man
den anbietern die viel geld verdienen
mit den mobilfunknetzen nicht auferlegt
dass sie die gesamte fläche abdecken ist
ist ja die wähler den haushalten ist
jetzt in den versorgungs auflagen auch
die fläche drin ist hab ich vielleicht
mal vergessen und uns auf das ja da
haben wir zu 97,5 und diese 2,5 prozent
tun uns richtig weh weil es 2005 nein
nein
bis ende 2022 müssen die flächen
deckungen erfüllt seien auch die
schließen der weißen fleck der feind ist
nicht jeder ort in deutschland wird dein
handy netze ich sage ihnen zwei
geschichten die
ein versprechen
deswegen habe ich bin
dann ich bin oben sie zur politik und
wer genau anschauen
ich bin jetzt ein kontrolleur der
regierung und wir haben das vereinbart
mit den netzanbietern das vertraglich
zugesichert ihm ursache zu sagen ich
habe morgen wieder eine runde zur
vergabe von förderbescheiden zum thema 5
gb 5 geht's immer weltweit sogar
ziemlich spitze als deutschland weil wir
mit diesem ausbau millionen von
haushalten schon jetzt vor dem
ausbauplan erreichen und was für die
wirtschaft wichtig ist so genannte
campus lösungen für den mittelstand etc
die 5g abdeckung hinbekommen sehr
positiv und das zweite ist wir müssen
die mobilfunkinfrastruktur gesellschaft
zum schließen der weißen flecken jetzt
ans wirklich netz bringen das sind 1,1
milliarden euro zur verfügung um genau
diese dörfer abgelegenen orte zu
erschließen wo jetzt keine
wirtschaftlichkeit beim ausbau gegeben
ist und der dritte geschichte wenn ihr
das nur sagen es war ein fehler dass wir
die mobilfunkmasten von vor ort
genehmigt lassen von den gremien von vor
ort weil was ich feststelle wir können
noch so viele förderprogramme
machen es scheitert nicht am geld sowohl
bei breiter nicht als auch beim
mobilfunk nummer rechten sie deren
strahlt der mobilfunkmast wird vor ort
im gremium im dorf in der gemeinde in
der stadt xy genehmigt und da haben wir
den flaschenhals wenig der ampel was
empfehlen dürfte dann würde ich mal
sagen gibt es in die hand der
bundeszuständigkeit man wieder völlig
genesen
sie haben vollkommen recht wir haben ein
neues telekommunikationsgesetz auf den
weg gebracht wo die möglichkeiten sind
die flächen besser zu nutzen auch die
wegerechte und vieles mehr das ist
positiv jetzt vor ein paar wochen an den
start gegangen aber den durchbruch zu
erzielen das stelle ich einfach fest
dass viele vor ort angst haben für eine
diskussion wenn ein mobilfunkmast
gestellt wird das lasse ich mir selber
auch als kritik an völlig zu recht weil
dann würde der ausbau schneller gehen
das ehrt sie dass sie das so machen weil
das ja nicht immer nennt es bei jedem
politiker am ende einer amtszeit auch
sagen da habe ich sicherlich noch ein
bisschen was verloren meine ich ehrlich
mit großem respekt eine andere frage
aber weil die verkehrsminister sind
gerade von kontrolle gesprochen haben
haben sie eigentlich heute ihren
fraktionskollegen philipp amthor den
kopf gewaschen nur dann habe ich nicht
gesehen habt der war gar nicht da ich
habe ihn aber erst ein spiel verloren
ist mir sagen muss 54 euro zwar schnell
gefahren und der verkehrsminister was
macht er zieht den führerschein ich
werde sicherlich einziehen die wir nicht
persönlich einziehen aber sie haben
nicht gesehen also das heißt er war
heute
nicht dabei war wahrscheinlich noch
unterwegs also ich wollte immer mit
dabei und vielleicht zum schluss dieser
dieser handy debatte sagen es wird ja
wahrscheinlich digital ministerium geben
nehmen nicht gibt s nicht was ich höre
ich nicht nicht also ganze zahlt dann
hab ich schon mal gleich einen nagel in
den sarg deckeln denn davon bin ich fest
ausgegangen dass die fdp einen digitalen
minister hat jede im wahlprogramm
aussehen machen soll es sollte es das
nicht geben dann gibt es wieder so ein
misch ministerium warum fünf aufgaben
ineinander fließen und dann wird es
wieder nix also ich dachte wir müssen
uns in fdp menschen gleich greifen der
dafür zuständig ist und in hier
einschwören ja
aus meiner erfahrung ich baue für die
digitale infrastruktur zuständig wenn
heute ein bundesministerium nicht
digital ist dann haben fehler gemacht es
muss eigentlich jedes bundesministerium
heute digital sein ein kleines digital
ministerium sein weil der
arbeitsminister genauso wie themen in
seiner verwaltung hat was die
digitalisierungs betrifft wie der
verkehrsminister also es ist generell
muss jedes ministerium im bund und land
heute ein kleiner steht mich ein
bisschen aber noch los das robert koch
institut die ganze pandemie steuert ist
nicht digital
für dafür dass kannibale junges kraft
vom bundesamt waren wir gerade bei
philips am tor waren das ist eine
behörde beispielsweise von mir die hohe
digitalisiert ist und vor allem einen
wirklich gute entwicklung gemacht hat
genauso frau schenk wenig seltsam da
haben sie auch die letzten der deutsche
wetterdienst schafft jetzt den datenraum
mobilität wo wir alle davon profitieren
weil wenn wir dann die daten dahin
bekommen auch durch den deutschen
wetterdienst dann können wir besser
unterwegs sein und länder und bei den
datenschutzbeauftragten von bund und
länder noch mehr
digitalisierungs instinkt da ist das
mein ganzer kopf ist jetzt von mobilfunk
gipfel hier ein papier hier
so macht
ich bin hammam durch mecklenburg
vorpommern wenn die jetzt sagen ich weiß
was meine chaos koalition
trotzdem meine verträge weiter führt
dann werden sie ende 2002 ein neues
lächeln student
2022 wird es flächendeckend
mobilfunknetz geben sagt
die telefonate bis dahin
sind sie schon den oppositions modus das
ist schon mal nicht schlecht dass wir
nachricht an haider zu werden